you really think that climate change is
the biggest challenge that we face as a
global community
you really feel the power of landscape
but then at the same time the fragility
of it as well and it was unseasonable
warm the summer that we were there it
was like sixty degrees some days and we
were out in a t-shirt on our boat and
you can literally see the ice melting in
front of your eyes
the reason why I wanted to go to these
two very seemingly disparate landscapes
and draw the connection for people is to
you know help people recognize that it's
everywhere is being affected in one way
or another
the idea is that people see the drawings
having an emotional connection to the
work and then to that landscape and then
ideally be inspired to protect and
preserve it
the paintings that I did for the
unbroken show are very much related to
my injury